moving forward what are the main changes
that you think
people should expect uh especially in
the american media
and culture without trump in office
anymore obviously we had this
knife edge that it was could it go one
way could it go another and
four more years we could have probably
had a good understanding of what to
expect just more of the same
but now that he's no longer there what
do you reckon is going to happen
it's it is going to be so demented this
year
that people have no idea uh
what's coming it's been what two weeks
into the biden administration
and we're already seeing like they're
talking about putting on second masks
and you know what we're just seeing with
gamestop and so on and so forth
um the thing with chaos and chaos and
anarchy you're not synonymous but i'm a
fan of both
is you never know you know where it's
going to be coming one of my favorite
moments of the trump
um presidency was there was some dispute
between him and the speaker of the house
nancy pelosi
and there was an entire busload of
democratic congressmen
and they were going to take a plane to
visit an american base i think maybe in
iraq or something
and trump as commander-in-chief pulled
the authorization for the military plane
so they had to bring the bus back to the
capitol they all have to get off the bus
like the school trip's been canceled
and we were just sitting there peeing
our pants as all these congressmen just
didn't know what because they had they
had to get off the bus and that had to
be on video
and it was just a complete humiliation
no one could have predicted that
so i think without trump without this
centralized figure
we are going to see things like you were
talking about this wall street bet stuff
so many more um
uh attempts and successful executions
of things that are no one saw coming
and are going to be hilarious and that
will demonstrate
how much of the um claim
to elite control is completely
fraudulent that these people are not
better that they're not particularly
smarter
they're certainly not more moral uh and
the more that's exposed the more hopeful
people will become from the future
because it's one thing to say
look you're going to be ruled by a bunch
of thieves
fine you know maybe you need that maybe
you need those deeds in charge to make
sure like
i'd rather have the thieves than the
murderers right but
let's be honest that you are thieves and
that i think is would be
a good starting point to go forward and
i think that's increasingly happening
what's the difference between a trump
administration and a biden
administration why does a biden
administration
garner more chaos than the trump one i
would have thought the trump one would
have been more chaotic
because with trump um people
who would have disdain for the system
a large part of them felt represented
they felt okay we have someone who
thinks like i do
we have someone who hates the things i
hate he's speaking for me i have a voice
now they feel like okay no one's
speaking for me i have no
commitment to this system i have no
investment here
i'm being told i'm a white supremacist
insurrectionist on a daily basis so okay
if that's how you regard if i'm
not if you regard me as a nazi if you're
going to read me out of the human race
then we can't really go forward having a
conversation i don't want to
sit down and have a conversation with
the nazi well i did for my book but not
certainly in a collegial
kind of way like oh you know where your
kids going to school oh nice seeing you
so on and so forth so
i think it's going to be much more uh
systemic
breaking down and we're seeing in europe
so if you follow european elections
it's becoming harder and harder for
different countries to form governing
coalitions
um belgium was the great example where
there's two halves of belgium from
getting this country right one
was socialist the other now the white
nationalists were in charge because they
speak different languages
you're not going to be able to sit down
and work with each other we had this
in thiringia and germany where they had
a negative coalition meaning
the far left and the afd the
nationalists had enough seats that
between them no one could make a
majority
and they didn't know what to do so and
now in italy
what's happening is for a long time you
had um
berlusconi's party right he was the
center-right party uh before
italia uh you know they were the
right-wing ones and then as it was
after he kind of fell away you had
matteo salvini the league
you guys are nazis you guys are nazis
you guys are nazis they got into
government
well what happened then is now that they
recall the nazis
they're losing some support but the
neo-fascists are gaining support
so when you are forcing people to pay
the costs
of having views that are extreme at a
certain point they're going to be like
you know what i am going to check these
people out because that's what you're
calling me
and they're the ones who want to talk to
me and you don't this is a very
dangerous game these people are playing
um and they are so up their own ass
and are so not used to thinking
strategically that all they
know how to do would just repeat what
they've said before and i
all i could do is caution and be like
you are doing a very
dangerous thing and i'm saying this as
an anarchist who does not believe in
politics
that feels like an element of the thread
that we were talking about earlier on
that you have such a rapid pace emerges
on the bottom
and you have such a big lumbering
goliath up at the top
yeah that's exactly it and this huge
disconnect and this goliath
is complete if there's like i'm a big
zoology person
and the thing that brings down giraffes
are ticks
because in giraffe the surface area of a
giraffe is enormous that means you could
have so many ticks on a
draining of blood giving a disease it's
gonna be a lot easier for that
than for let's suppose a lion where if
the giraffe kicks in the head it once
it's dead
so this is i i i
think they're completely oblivious uh
they're always tell themselves in these
words that they're on the right side of
history
you know if someone comes up to me with
a knife telling them i'm on the right
side of history
is really going to be a very weak tool
and if it is a war
just saying i'm the good guys is really
not going to gain you anything
so that's what's happening emergently
that's what sort of the
the population is feeling what about top
down what do you see in terms of
administrative
changes or i guess top-down cultural
changes
i'm shocked by how quickly they've come
to realize
that wait a minute we didn't win because
they thought
very sincerely we got rid of trump
everything can go back to normal
unity and then it took a couple of weeks
and they're like holy crap none of these
trump people
who or who they described as trump
people like you know they would call
glenn greenwald the trump person none of
these people missed a beat
they're not going home they're not going
anywhere uh they've become
even more radicalized uh they've become
even more contemptuous of us
what do we do well and they're not
really they are just i think at this
point they're still confused
and they're going to become a lot more
confused or
they're going to start implementing
smart strategies which i wouldn't bet on
uh if they want to if they know what's
good for them and i don't say that as a
threat i'm saying i'm saying that
someone who's very afraid
are you seeing this with the amount of
executive orders that biden's put in for
instance that it's just
a hammer blow it's using i'm seeing
here's another example
like uh for three years we heard that
uh the 2016 election was you know
undermined by russia
and there was trump was impeached over
this and russia russia russia russia
there's a conspiracy and there was
collusion with
trump and putin within a week of this
past election
every corporate media outlet was saying
this has been the most secure election
history
it is not possible to make that
statement with that quickly
you haven't invested it might be true
but you couldn't in a week
you know do all the investigations see
all the mistakes see whatever was fixed
and how was it that president trump and
all these republican governors oversaw
it going from russia
to now it's completely secure this is a
clearly
and to just to dispute this in any way
is grounds from getting you removed from
social media until you should be
silenced and now you believe in
insurrection and civil war and all this
other stuff
this is not the approach of an elite
that feels secure
and in control this is someone if
if someone if you and me are having an
argument in your house
i'll say my piece you'll see your piece
you know maybe our voices will get
raised
if i'm shoving you out of the house and
locking the door i don't feel safe
and that's what they are trying to do
the problem is they don't really own the
house anymore
like they do not have a monopoly over
the mechanisms of
um conversation and that when you have
an edifice built and deception being
able to speak
even critically is an enormous
existential threat to it
are we seeing again this is another one
of those threads that appears to be
tying together
the same way as executive orders the
same way as restrictions with regards to
speech the same way as the press
restricting people's movements the same
way as robin hood restricting people's
trades
is this the last vestiges of the old
guard trying to hold on to their version
of power
or how they used to be able to deploy
power and it seems like
if they were to go about it in a more
smart way
this is the 1984 element of a brave new
world the fact that there is only so far
that you can try to cajole and coerce
and
and tempt people into things until you
need to get the hammer out and hit him
over the head
yeah and we're seeing a lot more hammers
appear and that as you said is when it's
really really obvious that someone's
decided okay
gloves are off rules are broken i need
to i need to press the [ __ ] ejector c
button
and it's also very expensive in the
sense of if you and i have a fight
whatever
hey sorry man i was really upset no no
it's cool
if you punch me in the face or i punch
you in the face you can never undo that
and that's also shown me several things
one you're a person is capable of
violence against me or vice versa
and you're someone who is can do that
again in the future
this is not it goes very hard to reverse
that
and to try to have some kind of
relationship that's at all based on
respect
or working together it's like all right
you did this to me once
also now there's an enormous pressure i
have to make sure i'm not in that
position again
because i'm sorry it was a mistake it's
like you know what if i get punched a
second time at some point
it's going to be part of my fault that i
trusted you so this is
when they have to use this kajo like you
pointed out or this hammer
this is enormously expensive on that for
them in terms of future relationships
because that is something that can't be
unseen or undone you can't ring that
bell
and it's not just necessarily the person
who gets the cudgel out
right it's everybody else within
that domain and perhaps this is why
we're seeing such a proliferation
of telegram and discord and signal you
know i've i saw
i can't remember who let me give you a
great example this hold on look so one
of the big things
i've been working on this past year was
uh turning people against the police
and i have never seen any population
switch its views on a fundamental issue
as
quickly as in america at least
conservatives have turned the police
for a very long time you could not talk
them about it
the police are what keeps us from being
you know in a state of anarchy haha
a state of complete violence everyone be
killing each other and then all you had
to do is a little bit of footage there
was canada
where they broke into someone's house
because they were having thanksgiving
dinner whatever it was
and pulled an old man out of the house
and when you see that video it's like
okay
i can never pretend some people still
can that
okay they're keeping us safe they're
just like you and me
good apples you look at that you're like
i don't know you don't have to know
anything about politics
to know something somewhere has taken a
very drastic turn
when old people who are not you know gun
runners or drug dealers or running a
brothel
are being violently pulled out of their
homes by the police
this is not like you're lo it's like
you're doing accounting
and all of a sudden you have like a
million dollar deficit it's like okay
somewhere the math went way wrong